امريكا والمانيا اليوم عن تسليم اوكرانيا
دبابات متطوره وروسيا تدعوا لوقف دقات
الساعه النوويه
منورات عسكريه بين اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده تحاكي ضربه منشات النوويه ايرانيه
ب 100 طن من القنابل
اوامر عليا في كوريا الشماليه باغلاق
العاصمه خمسه ايام بسبب انتشار مرض
التنفسي غير محدد حتى الان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا نشره تطورات ارسال
دبابات
اليوم بالتزامني بين واشنطن وبرلين في هذا
السياق افادت مصادر رسميه امريكيه لشبكه
سي ان بانه واشنطن تتجه
للاعلان عن ارسال 30 دبابه من طراز ابرامز
لاوكرانيا خلال الاسبوع الجاري واشارت
المصادر الى ان الاداره الامريكيه تضع
اللامسات الاخيره على خطوط الارسال كما
اوضحت المصادر المسؤوله للشبكه الامريكيه
ان قرار التسليم اكيد لكن عمليه الارسال
قد تستغرق وقتا الى ذلك قالت المصادر
نفسها ان حزمه المساعدات العسكريه
سيتضمن عددا مركبات الانقاذ والجر التي
تمكن قوه الاوكانيه من قطر واصلاح
الدبابات في ارض المعركه
في المانيا افادت وكاله الانباء الالمانيه
بان المستشار الالماني سيعلن اليوم ارسال
دبابات اليوبار الى اوكرانيا كما انه منح
الاذن بيعاده تصدير الدبابات من قبل الدول
الاوروبيه بولندا بدورها قال صحيفه اول
سيرينا ان امريكا والمانيا سترسلان عددا
قليلا من الذبابات في اطار صفقه في وقت
اكدت مصادر امريكيه ان الاعلان الامريكيه
قد يكون الاربعاء ايضا فيما كشفت صحيفه
ديرشبيل الالمانيه
ولكن موعد الوصول غير محدد
دعا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديميتر
من قاده الولايات المتحده والمانيا لوقف
دقات عقارب الساعه النوويه مؤكدا انه يجب
اولا ان يدركوا ان سهمهم الاوكراني قد عله
الصدى
على السؤال اما العمل لاعاده هذه الساعه
الوراء حيث قال انه يجب على صانع الساعات
بيض وجودت اني يتوقف بل ان يوقف دقات
السعدديه لفتره من الوقت
بدوره وصفت سفير الروسي لدى الولايات
المتحده انا طولي انت نور عمليات التسليم
دبابات قتاليه محتمله من قبل واشنطن
لاوكرانيا بالاستفزازات الصواريخ الجديد
لروسيا وقال ان تنوفي تصريحات نشرت على
تطبيق تيليجرام ان واشنطن وبكل وضوح تحاول
عن قصد الحاقه هزيمه الاستراتيجيه واضاف
ان تنوف انه اذا قررت الولايات المتحده
تزبيده اوكرانيا بالدبابات فان تبرير مثل
هذه الخطوه بالحجج حول الاسلحه الدفاعيه
لان ينجح بالتاكيد
يطالب الدول الغربيه باتخاد قرارات سريعه
لتسليم بلاده دفعه جديده من الدبابات
الحديثه والمتطوره
عن الدبابات الحديثه التي نحتاجها هناك
الكثير من الجهود والوعود ولكن يجب الا
تغيب عن بالنا الوقائع فالامر لا يتعلق
بخمس او عشر او خمس عشره دبابه فقط الحاجه
اكبر من ذلك بكثير نحن نفعل يوميا كل ما
هو ضروري لسان هذا النقص في الدبابات
واشكر كل من يدعمنا في هذا الشان لكن
المناقشات يجب ان تؤدي الى قرارات بشان
التعزيز الحقيقي لمواجهه الارهابيين لدى
حلفائنا العدد المطلوب من الدبابات وعندما
يتوصلون الى القرار المناسب عندها يسعدنا
ان نشكرهم على ذلك
بدله كبيره اذا احدثتها دبابات ليوبارتوال
المانيه هل تعطيها المانيا ام لا وهل تسمح
لاخرين بتصيعها هذا الاسرار الاوكراني
اولا والغربي ثانيا على تزويد اكياس بهذه
الدبابات اسبابهم متعدده لكن اهم هذه
الاسباب ان لا يعتبر ستشكل نقل نوعيه في
الحرب مع منحها القوات الاوكرانيه القطنيه
عن نوع نفسه في ثلاث دول اخرى بترخيص من
المانيا وتستخدمها جيوش احدى وعشرين دوله
في الناتو تشير التقديرات مشاهدينا
الحاليه الى وجود نحو الفي دبابات ليوبار
تو في اوروبا اكثر من 423 دبابه منها
مخزنه في المانيا وفقا للمعهد الدولي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه تركيا تملك 316
دبابه
تليها بولندا مع دبابتين واليونان مع مئه
وثلاثون دبابه
سويسرا فتمتلك همم من دبابات اليابان
134 قضيتين و20 دبابه اخرى بحلول نهايه
العام الحالي كما اكدت مشاهدينا الشركه
الالمانيه امكانيه ارسال 88 دبابه من طراز
88 دبابه من طراز لاوبر وان دون تحديد
الموعد حتى الساعه
قواتها وتكثف الهجوم على مدينه باخم
وتداعيا العالم الى مساندته من اجل مواجهه
ما وصفه بالجرائم الروسيه الجديده
وهي تستمر بزياده ضغطها على مخموط وفولدار
ومواقع اخرى
المسؤولون الروسي يريدون تجنب الاخضر
السابقه ولذلك سيحشدون في هجومهم غالبيه
رجالهم وعتابهم بالتالي يتعين علينا جميعا
في العالم الحر ان نعزز تعاوننا من اجل
مواجهه الجرائم الروسيه الجديده من اجل
مواجهه الجرائم الروسيه الجديده
في هذا الاطار افاد تقرير لصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز بان البنتاجون يخططه لزياده انتاج
قذائف المدفعيه لصالح اوكرانيا بنسبه 500
في المئه خلال العامين المقبلين وهذه
الكميه من الانتاج حسب الصحيفه تصل الى
مستويات لم يسبق لها مثيل منذ الحرب
الكوريه حيث تنفق وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
مليارات الدولارات لتعويض نقص الناجم عن
الحرب في اوكرانيا وبناء مخزونات للصراعات
المستقبليه حسب التقرير
وبعد بل في اجواء الاستقالات وتهم الفساد
التي تلاحق قاده في الجيش الاوكراني ذكر
صحيفه ثياب عند
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
ورثاء مليون دولار من الامريكيه
الاوكرانيه جيولوجيه
فيما اكد المكتب الاعلامي والتابع الجيش
الاوكراني لصحيفه تايمز ان المبلغ الذي
حصل عليه رئيس الاركان كاميرات وصل
بالاوسط بدعم الجيش الاولاني
وبعد الاتهامات الروسيه لاوكرانيا بنشر
اسلحه وذخائر في المحطه النوويه ابلغ
المدير العام وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
رفع الجرس البرلمان الاوروبي بان تفتيشا
للمحطات النوويه الاوكرانيه لم يؤكد
العثور على اي معدات عسكريه وقال روسي ان
هذه هي المره الثانيه التي تتمكن فيها
الوكاله من ضغط الاتهامات بحدوث اموهم غير
قانونيه
الى اتهامات سابقه بشان صنع قنبله خطيره
مشاهدينا ووسط تدهود العلاقات بين
ستوكهولم وانقره قال رئيس السويد الفا
كريسترسون انه يامل في العوده الى حوار
عمل مع تركيا
انه يريد العوده الى حوار بطريقه هادئه
مشيرا الى اتفاق تراثيين بين السويد
اوفلندا وتركيا واضاف رئيس وزراء السويد
انه لا يعتقد ان الرئيس التركي اغلق الباب
بشان مساله عضويه في حلف شمال الاطلسي
نشاط المستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
اجراءات امنيه تصاحب تظاهره للعراقيين
اليوم امام البنك المركزي بسبب ازمه
الدينار
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد
المشتركه بين القوات الجويه الاسرائيليه
والقياده المركزيه الامريكيه سيقصف اهداف
تحاكي مواقع ايرانيه اليوم الاربعاء
صواريخ في التمرين المشترك الذي سيصل الذي
سيصل اليوم الاربعاء
في اسرائيل ايضا مشاهدينا وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي بنوفير يقول ساستمر
بزياره المسجد الاقصى هذا حسب الانباء
اخبار العجله يظهر على شاشه العربيه الان
فيما يتصل بالملف النووي اكدت نائبه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه والنشر من خلال خطاب
لها في ولايه كليفلاند ان العوده الى
الاتفاق النوويه الايرانيه لا تزال ممكنه
وقال شيرمان ان خطه العمل الشاميه
المشتركه المعروف باسم الاتفاق النووي لا
تزال احد الخيارات الممكنه لكنها ليست على
جدول الاعمال الان
حسب التقرير لشبكه السي ان ان الامريكيه
فانه مع تراجع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في
ايران بشكل تدريجي نتيجه الاساليب القمعيه
التي يستخدمها النظام الايراني الا ان
الاستياء الشعبيه يزداد
اساليب قمعيه واعدامات متتاليه كانت هي
السلاح الابرز للنظام الايراني لمواجهه
الغضب الشعبي وبعد مرور اربعه اشهر من
الاحتجاجات وتنامل استياء الشعبي بشكل غير
مسبوق تلاشا زخم التظاهرات لكن الغضب في
اعلى مستوياته الاحكام القاسيه التي كانت
موجهه ضد المنشقين والاقليات العرقيه
والنساء على وجه التحديد
جعلت بقيه المتظاهرين الايرانيين يخشون من
مواجهه نفس المصير
سلسله الاعدامات لم تكن السبب الوحيد في
تلاش هذه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
بالرصاص والاعتقالات الجماعيه والاعتداء
الجسدي والعنف الجنسي
كلها عوامل اساسيه كان لها دور في انخفاض
المعارضه من الشارع الايراني من جهه
وازدياد الاستياء الشعبي العام من جهه
اخرى
وتحديدا في المناطق الحدوديه التي تهيمن
عليها الاقليات والتي تحملت العب الاكبر
من قمع النظام
وكما يرى مراقبون فان معظم الاشخاص الذين
تزيد اعمارهم عن 25 عاما ابتعدوا عن
المظاهرات
بالاضافه الى الجيل الاكبر سنا منهم
والذين ضلوا الى حد كبير بعيدا عن الشوارع
التي تعمها الاحتجاجات
وهو الامر الذي حرم الحركه الاحتجاجيه
الزخم اللازمه لاسقاط النظام الايراني
وسطى توقعاتهم بان تعود هذه الانتفاضه
مجددا ضد النظام الايراني بسبب عدم قدرته
على معالجه المشاكل الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه
بسبب العقوبات الدوليه المفروضه عليها
سلطان العربيه
في ليبيا قالت حكومه فتحي باشا غير مكلفه
من البرلمان ان عزمه رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا
جورج ميلني حضور توقيع اتفاق النفطي جديد
اما حكومه الوحده الوطنيه برئاسه عبد
الحميد الدبابه هو سلوك انتهازي يغامر
بالعالم
ولا تتمتع باهليه توقيع اي اتفاقيات او
مذكره تفاهم واشار بيان الحكومه الليبيه
المكلفه الى الاعداد لصفقه وصفها بالغامضه
بين المؤسسه الوطنيه
والتي قال انها تقضي بالزياده حصه الشريك
الاجنبي وتقليص حصه الشريك الوطني
اكدت نقابه النقل التابعه لاتحاد التونسي
للشغل ان موعد اضراب قطاع برا وبحرا وجوا
سيتاجل الى يوم الخميس عشر والسادس عشر من
مارس المقبل وفقا ما ذكره مسؤول نقابي
المصدر ذاته قال في تصريح للاعلام المحلي
ان الاضراب قائم في ظل تواصل تجاهل
الحكومه لمطالب القطاع واقرارها مرسوما
لخصخصه المؤسسات العموميه على حد تعبيره
في العراق كشفت قياده عمليات بغداد عن خطه
متكامله لتامين الحمايه المحتاجين خلال
التظاهره المرتقبه اليوم قرب البنك
المركزي احتجاجا على ارتفاع سعر صرف
الدولار مقابل الدينار وقال قائد عمليات
بغداد الفريق الركن احمد سليم ان القياده
والزعه القطاعات الامنيه المتمثله بوحدات
حفظ القانون وهي وحدات متخصصه من وزاره
الداخليه لتوفير الحمايه المتظاهرين
في بغداد
اكدى محمد
رئيس الامريكي السابق العثور على وثائق
السريه في منزل
الاسبوع الماضي وتم احالتها الى مكتب
التحقيقات الاتحادي العثور على وثائق
مصنفه سريه في منازل الرؤساء الامريكيين
ونوابهم يدل على ان المشكله تكمله في
ترقيم هذه الوثائق والتاكدي لمن يحتفظ بها
وكيفيه استرجاعها تقرير في العالم
تبدو قضيه الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها
الرئيس الحالي جو فايدن والرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب مؤشرا على مشكله حقيقيه
تواجهها اجهزه الدوله الامريكيه مع
الرؤساء الامريكيين
السيناتور الديمقراطيه
كشفها كيف يتم التعامل مع الوثائق المصنفه
الذريه خلال اللقاء التلفزيون
لكن المساله مختلفه مع الرئيس الامريكي من
الممكن ان نرى الرئيس سبايدر وهو يغادر
وبيده اوراق ويذهب الى مقر الاقامه في
المبنى الرئيسي من البيت الابيض او الى
الطائره لا احد يتابع مع الرئيس الامريكي
ما حصل للاوراق المصنفه السريه
ولا احد يسال عنها او يطلب استعادتها من
الرئيس عندما يغادر او عندما ينتهي من
استعمالها هذه واحده من المشاكل لكن ما
حصل مع بيضه ومن قبله ترامب يتراوح بين
الاهمال والاصرار على عدم احترام
الاجراءات الامنيه وحمايه الوثائق السريه
فبعض الوثائق موجود بحوزه بايضا منذ كان
عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي وقبل ان يصبح
نائبا للرئيس العام
طبعا يجب ان يتبعه نظام المكتبات العامه
وعندما يعطى الرئيس وثيقه وهي عاده تاتي
من السي اي اي او وزاره الدفاع يجب ان
تكون مسجله ومرقمه
الحل الاخر المطروح هو تحويل كل الوثائق
السريه الى النظام الالكتروني وبالتالي
يقفل الدخول اليها بمجرد انتهاء الرئيس من
استعمالها وهذا ما حصل في الاجاز الامني
للرئيس في المكتب البيضاوي في الغانم
العربيه
طولك فيسبوك رسميا نصيب رئيس الوزراء
نيوزيلندا خلف اللجان التي فاجات
نيوزلنديا الاسبوع الماضي باعلان
استقالتها والذهب كنز اليمين الدستوريه
امام الحاكم العملي لنيوزيلندا خلال حفل
الاقامه في العاصمه
امرت السلطات في كوريا الشماليه بفرض
اغلاق كامل لمده خمسه ايام في العاصمه
بيونغيان ارتفاع الاصابات بمرض تنفسي لم
تحدده حسب ما ذكر موقع ان كان يوز ومقره
صول ولم يشري الموقع الذي يرصده اخبار
كوريا الشماليه الى ظاهره كورونا لكنه
اوضح هذا السكان في المدينه الكوريه
الشماليه عليهم البقاء في منازلهم ويجب ان
يخضعوا لقياس درجه الحراره عده مرات في
اليوم
نقص في امدادات الدواء يشهده العالم خاصه
المضادات الحيويه اثر مشاكل الطاقه
الانتاجيه والزياده في الطلب ومشاكل
التوريد العالمي اذا [__] ذلك مع الشغال
الشركات الدواء بتصنيع اللقاحنا
بعد ازمه كورونا والحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وتبعتها من ازمه طاقه وتضخم
يواجه العالم تحديا اخر نقص في امدادات
الدواء على مستوى العالم حيث اعترفت
اوروبا اليوم بانها تواجه تحديا كبيرا في
نقص الادويه
هيئه الدواء الاوروبيه طلبت بالعمل على
مواجهه تناقص امدادات المضادات الحيويه
وادويه خفض الحراره والفلسلين
وكالات الاوروبيه عده اكدت ان الطلبه
المتزايده على المضادات الحيويه مصدر قلم
كما عزت الاسباب الى الاحداث السياسيه على
مستوى العالم وقضايا سلسله التوريد
العالميه وانشغال الشركات الطبيه بتصنيع
اللقاحات كروما
الاسباب الجذريه لنقص الادويه معقده
وتتعلق بعوامل كثيره مثل مشاكل الطاقه
الانتاجيه وزيادات غير متوقعه في الطلب
المفوضيه الاوروبيه وضمان الامدادات
وتنظيم عمليات الشراء المشتركه بدات
بتخزين الادويه والزام المصنعين
ليست القاره العجوز الوحيده في مواجهه
النقص بل حتى الولايات المتحده تعاني ايضا
من نقص في المضاد الحيوي وتواجه الصين
عاوزا في الادويه في مشافيها ما يهدد
المناطق الريفيه بالتزامن مع الزياد
الاصابات بفيروس كورولا
اما الرئيس الروسي فقد اقر بوجود نقص في
الادويه في بلاده وطالب بالتحقيق والعمل
على توفيرها
ازمه دواء صامته تجتاح العالم وهي مرتبطه
بنقص انتاج شركات الكبرى في مصانعها في
الدول الاقل كلفه بسبب التضخم والحرب ونقص
المواد التي تدخل في صناعه الدواء
وفي نهايه
امريكا والمانيا تعتذيمان الاعلان اليوم
عن تسليم اوكرانيا دبابات متطوره وروسيا
تدعوا لوقف دقات الساعه النوويه
مناورات عسكريه بين اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده تحاكي ضرب منشاه نوويه ايرانيه ب
100 طن من القنابل
اوامر عليا في كوريا الشماليه باغلاق
العاصمه خمسه ايام بسبب انتشار مرض
التنفسيه غير محدد حتى الان
نهايه هذه النشره مشاهدينا كونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]